este lunes el joven acusado de haber
llevado a cabo la matanza en un
supermercado de la Ciudad de Búfalo se
ha declarado culpable el 14 de mayo
asesinó a 10 personas afroe
estadounidenses un acto calificado de
racista y terrorista
nuestro cliente se ha declarado culpable
de todos los cargos Sabiendo
perfectamente que pasará el resto de su
vida en prisión
las autoridades dicen que el autor
confesó de 19 años buscaba
específicamente matar a personas afroe
estadounidenses cuando abrió Fuego en la
tienda según Los investigadores el
atacante público en internet antes del
tiroteo un discurso racista en el que se
declaraba Suprema si está blanco y
prometía matar a afroamericanos
investigó y se dirigió específicamente a
la tienda Tops de la avenida Jefferson
por su ubicación incluso llegó a ser una
búsqueda de Google del código postal del
estado de Nueva York que tenía la mayor
concentración de afroamericanos
este masacre tuvo lugar solo 10 días
después de otra matanza perpetrada por
un joven de 18 años que mató a 19 niños
y dos profesores en una escuela de
uvaldi en Texas desde entonces han
aumentado el número de tiroteos masivos
alimentando la frustración de los
estadounidenses frente a la falta de
solución respecto a la multiplicación de
matanzas el presidente demócrata
dubaidane todavía no ha conseguido
impulsar en el congreso la prohibición
de los fusiles de asalto debido a la
oposición republicana